.
RO: GIANNIS WITH HIS NINTH
STRAIGHT PLAYOFF DOUBLE-DOUBLE.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> A MONSTER NIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU GUYS
COULD HAVE DONE BETTER?
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT STARTS
EARLY?
HOW DO YOU VIEW THAT?
GIANNIS: WHAT COULD WE HAVE DONE
BETTER ON K.D.?
OH, MAN.
YOU HAVE BEEN AROUND US A LONG
TIME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION.
>> THE FIRST THINGS THAT COME TO
MIND, YOU COULD HAVE GUARDED
HIM.
GIANNIS: ME PERSONALLY?
>> YES.
GIANNIS: WHAT'S THE SECOND?
>> THE SECOND WOULD BE TO DOUBLE
THE BALL OUT OF HIS HANDS.
GIANNIS: I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
JUST KEEP MAKING IT TOUGH, ONE
OF THE BEST SCORERS TO PLAY THE
GAME.
IT'S TOUGH.
HE IS THE BEST PLAYER IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW AND WE HAVE GOT
TO BEAT HIM AS A TEAM, GUARD HIM
AS A TEAM, MAKE HIM MAKE TOUGH
SHOTS, LIKE TONIGHT.
WE HAVE GOT TO KEEP DOING OUR
JOB AND HOPEFULLY HE IS GOING TO
MISS.
BUT WE HAVE TO KEEP DOING OUR
JOB, GUARDING TOGETHER, KEEP
MAKING IT TOUGH, KEEP PICKING
HIM UP FULL-COURT.
THERE IS GOING TO BE TIMES IN
THE GAME WHEN COACH TELLS US TO
DOUBLE-TEAM HIM, WE DOUBLE-TEAM.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE GOT TO KEEP
CONTAINING HIM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE HAS
DONE AN UNBELIEVABLE JOB.
BEST SCORER IN THE WORLD.
THERE'S GOING TO BE NIGHTS HE
DOES WHAT HE DID TONIGHT AND
NIGHTS WHEN WE CONTAIN HIM AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND GIVE
OURSELVES A CHANCE TO BE IN THE
GAME AND A POSITION TO WIN THE
GAME.
ONE GUY CAN GUARD HIM, TWO GUYS
CAN GUARD HIM.
WE HAVE TO DO IT AS A TEAM.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE AT THE
HEAD OF THAT?
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU WOULD WANT
IN GAME SIX?
GIANNIS: FOR SURE.
I WANT TO TAKE THE CHALLENGE.
OBVIOUSLY EVERYBODY IS GOING TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO GUARD HIM.
I WO